[موسيقى]
اسعد الله مساءكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه التي نقدم من خلالها ابرز
اخباره ملفات السعوديه والخليج وهذه ابرز
عناوين اليوم
الملك سلمان يصدر عده اوامر ملكيه ويعينوا
سلمان الدوسري وزير للاعلام
في حرب اوكرانيا نقص السلاح يعرقل تصدي
القوات الاوكرانيه للهجمات الروسيه في
باقمت والقوات الروسيه تحاصر المدينه
فالمؤتمر العدلي الدولي السعوديه تعزز
انظمه القضاء بالتحول الرقمي وتمنح اول
ترخيص لمكاتب محاماه اجنبيه
ومن ملفاتنا المتنوعه في الرابعه كذلك
في الكويت تكليف احمد نواف الصباح بتولي
رئاسه الوزراء وترشيح اعضاء الحكومه
الجديده
من المدينه المنوره الى العالم مشروع يسهل
التنقل في الحرم النبوي ويثري تجربه
الزوار في موسم الحج والعمره
حياكم الله نبدا بهذا الخبر الذي ورد قبل
قليل فقد اصدر خادم الحرمين الشريفين
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز عده اوامر
ملكيه بينها تعيين سلمان بن يوسف الدوسري
وزيرا للاعلام كما قضت الاوامر الملكيه
بتعيين ابراهيم بن محمد السلطان وزير
الدوله عضوا بمجلس الوزراء وتضمنت اوامر
خادم الحرمين الشريفين تعيين الفريق محمد
بن عامر الحربي نائبا لرئيس الاستخبارات
العامه
في ملف اخر وحول تطورات المتسارعه في
معركه باكمون افاده مراسل العربيه ان
المعارك استعرت بعد انتهاء مهله اخراج
المدنيين مشيرا الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تواجه صعوبه في المقاومه بسبب نقص السلاح
لكنها تصمم على التمسك بمواقعها وترفض
الانسحاب وقد اعلنت هيئه الاركان في الجيش
الاوكراني التصدي لاكثر من 130 هجوما
روسيا خلال 24 ساعه في اتجاهات
ولمانسك
وقالت الهيئه في بيانها اليومي ان القوات
الروسيه لا تتوقف عن محاولاتها لحصار
باخمت لكنها تواجه صعوبه في المحور الغربي
من جانبه اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
استمرار الضربات الجويه والنيران المدفعيه
في استهداف مواقع الجيش الاوكراني في
دانيتسكو اشاره الوزاره في بيانها اليومي
الى اسقاط 12 طائره مسيره اوكرانيه
واعتراض سته صواريخ هاي مارس خلال
العمليات واضافت ان قواتها الساده فت مقر
قياده كتيبه ازوب في دمرت مخزن اسلحه
اوكرانيا مخزن اسلحه اوكراني بالمقاطعه
ومن هنا يلتحق بنا مراسل العربيه رائد
الاغبر رائد مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
من الرياض اخر التطورات في باخمت كيف يمكن
وصفها
نهارك طيب نايف بالفعل ماذا زالت المعارك
مستمره ولا توقف في تبادل اطلاق النار ما
بين الطرفين ان كان على مستوى المقاطعه
هنا في دانياتك وان كان على مستوى مدينه
باخموت اخر التطورات في مدينه باقمت هو
انسحاب تدريجي وعلى شكل مجموعات صغيره
للقوات الاوكرانيه من الناحيه الغربيه
الشماليه حيث مدينه خروموفا هناك شهود
عيان اكدوا بان القوات الاوكرانيه بدات
تنسح تنسحب من هذا المحور بلده خروما هي
المتاخمه لبلده بغداد
والبعيده عن منطقه كراسنا التي
يعني كائنه على الخط السريع وهو خط الذي
يوصل الامدادات العسكريه للقوات
الاوكرانيه كما اسلفت شهود عيان يؤكدون
بان القوات الاوكرانيه بدات تنسحب من هذه
البلده تدريجيا على شكل مجموعات صغيره لكن
المعارك هناك ما زالت مستمره وهناك من هم
يدافعون عن البلده في المحور الغربي حتى
الان بينما تقاتل قوات فاجنر في جميع
المحاور الحديث عن الطوق كنصف هلال وعن
المناطق التي دخلوها اسخن المعارك داخل
المدينه في المنطقه الجنوبيه في محور
ساباشكا في هذا المحور ما زالت قوات فاجنر
تحاول التقدم اكثر للوصول الى قلب المدينه
القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت تدافع وتؤكد
بانها مستمره بالمقاومه هناك محاور اخرى
نايف لا تقل اهميه عن محور باقمت
كوبيانس كعاده القوات الروسيه بعد ان
انسحبت من مناطق كوبي
وتمركزت في كريمنايا لفتره طويله منذ ا
العام الماضي شهدت هذه الايام عوده للقوات
الروسيه
وتقدم على الارض يعني في اليومين الماضيين
كانت فقط ثلاثه كيلومترات تفصل الجيش
الروسي عن مدينه كوبيانسك اليوم وصلت جيش
الروسي الى تخوم المدينه ويحاول اقتحام
هناك ضربات بالمدفعيه الروسيه وبراجيمات
الصواريخ مع تقدم على الارض للمشاه هناك
خطه عسكريه للجيش الروسي لاستعاده هذه
المدن التي خسرها وفي ذلك الوقت يعني خسر
ثقه المؤيدين للعمليه العسكريه ربما هذه
العوده تعيد الثقه للمواطنين الروس الذين
ايدوا هذه العمليه من بياد من بدايتها اي
ثقتهم بالجيشه وامكاناته بالفعل اذا سمح
الوقت وبعجاله اكثر من خمسين الف قذيفه
وصاروخ تضرب من قبل الاجانب الروسي على
جميع المحاور
يوميا هذا ما يعني بان يعني التقارير التي
تحدثت عنها وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه بان
هناك نقص في الذخيره الروسيه على الارض
وميدانيا يعني لا يتفق مع هذه التصريحات
او على الاقل ينافي ما قالته وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه وانت صحفي موجود على الارض
تتابع هذه المعركه منذ بدايتها رائد
في الواقع نايف دائما وانا اتابع تقارير
الدفاع البريطانيه دائما ما تكون قريبه من
الواقع والحقيقه لكن خاصه في هذا التقرير
هذا هو بالفعل لا يتفق مع الواقع على
الارض لان الواقع على الارض لا توقف
للضربات وللقصف المتبادل ومن ناحيه روسيا
بكثافه بالفعل جميع المحاور تشهد تعزيزات
ايضا روسيه تعزيزات بشريه اضافه الى
الاليات وكما اسلفت بان وزاره الدفاع ايضا
الروسيه قالت بانها دمرت عشرات الاليات
والمدافع وصواريخ هايمارز اضافه الى ان
العدد الذي تقول الدفاع الروسيه بانها
تنحيح من الجنود الاوكران بشكل يومي هو
يصل الى 800 وكذلك تحدثت عن اسقاط اثنتي
عشره طائره مسيره ايضا زياده على صواريخ
هاي مارس التي ذكرت على كل حال شكرا جزيلا
لك على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل من
دانه مراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر شكرا يا
رائد
وتزامنا المشاهدين مع تصاعد المعارك اعلنت
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه عن توقيع اتفاق بين
كييف وعدد من الدول الاوروبيه تضم رومانيا
وبولندا وسلوفاكيا ودول البلطيق لانشاء
مركز معني بجريمه العدوان الروسي واضافت
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ان الاتفاق سيضفي
طابعا رسميا على الاجراءات الجنائيه وفتح
المجال امام محاكمه الذين يقفون وراء
الحرب بينهم الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
[موسيقى]
افادت وسائل اعلام ارمينيه بمقتل ثلاثه
جنود ارمينيين في اشتباك مع قوات
اذربيجانيه في ناغورنو كاراباخ بدورها
اكدت اذربيجان وقوع خسائر بشريه من جيشها
في اشتباكات مع القوات الارمينيه مشيره
الى استمرار الاشتباكات في ناغورنو
كاراباخ
اعتبر رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
يتنياهو ان تصريحات رئيس الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه رافايل جروسي غير جديره
لانه غير جديره به لانه شخص مسؤول وتسائل
نوتينياهو لماذا اعتبر جروسي ان اي هجوم
عسكري على المنشات النوويه الايرانيه امر
محظور مشيرا الى ان ايران تدعو بشكل واضح
الى تدمير اسرائيل وان العالم يدعم موقف
اسرائيل في الدفاع عن نفسها امام اي عدوان
المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه رفاهيل
جروسي اعلن في طهران ان الهجوم
الاسرائيليه على المنشات النوويه خارج عن
القانون خارج عن اي قانون بالنسبه لشخص
المسؤول مثل جروسي هل يجوز لايران التي
تدعو بصراحه ووضوح الى تدميرنا وان تحضر
الادوات لقتلنا من الواضح انه مسموح لنا
بالدفاع عن انفسنا من القدس ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه زي الحلبي زياد مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
جمله من التصريحات لرئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي نتنياهو انتقد فيها رافيل
جروسي كيف يمكن اجمال تلخيص هذه التصريحات
التي هاجم فيها رافاييل جروسي زياد
هذا صحيح جدا نايف عمليا كان واضحا بان
نتنياهو سيرد على هذا الموضوع وان اخذت
اسرائيل بعين الاعتبار بانك روسيا اطلق
هذه التصريحات في طهران في سياق جغرافي
بمعنى هو يتواجد هناك وقال هذا الموقف
نتنياهو طبعا كما اسلف في المقدمه قال ان
عمليا هذا التصريح غير صائب ولا يليق
بيجروسي لانه شخص مسؤول عاده لا يطلق مثل
هذه التصريحات لكن الواضح بحسب مراقبين
بان ثمه تاكلا انجاز التعبير في مكانه
اسرائيل الدوليه
وحتى في قضيه مواجهه النووي الايراني بسبب
ما يحدث في داخلها وبسبب الخلافات
المستمره مع واشنطن عمليا بان هناك الان
ضعفا في الدعم الخارجي لاسرائيل لمثل هذه
التصريحات والمواقف والافعال لجهه ايضا
العم الاسرائيليه السريه ضد النووي
الايراني هناك من يحذر داخل اسرائيل من
الخبراء بان استمرار الحرب الداخليه انجاز
التعبير على القضاء قد يؤدي الى اضعاف
قدره اسرائيل على تجنيد العالم لمساعدتها
في مواجهه النووي الايراني ومواجهه ايران
ككل وخاصه عند الحليف الاقوى والابرز وهو
الولايات المتحده هل لا زالت اسرائيل فعلا
زياد من خلال تصريحاتها الرسميه او ربما
حتى ما يدور احيانا دائما في الارويق
السياسيه هل ما زالت تعول على واشنطن في
الدفاع عن موقفها بسبب في مواجهه طبعا
البرنامج النووي الايراني ام هناك اختلاف
مع تغير الحكومه مع هذه الحكومه الجديده
المتشددا جاز التعبير
هناك شبه ياس انجاز التعبير من امكان ان
تقوم واشنطن عمليا بالمشاركه في عمليه
عسكريه قد تكون لازمه مع اسلوب ملامسه
ايران للتخصيب 90% يعني تستطيع في خلال 12
يوما ان تصل الى هذه النقطه ان كان ذلك من
الخطوط الحمراء الاسرائيليه لان الخط
الاحمر تغير خلال العقد الاخير ثلاث مرات
على ما اعلم ان كان ذلك من الخطوط الحمراء
بمعنى ان قامت ايران بشكل مفاجئ بالانطلاق
الى 90% تقصيبا قد يكون على اسرائيل ان
تشن عمليه عسكريه على المنشات النوويه
الايرانيه عمليا يعترف الاسرائيليون بانها
غير جاهزه بعد بمعنى هذه العمليه تحتاج
وفق التقديرات الاوليه الى ضربه اوليه
للمنشات فوق الارض ومن ثم الى غارات
متكرره ليس بمقدور اسرائيل بما تملكه من
سلاح جو وقدرات حاليا وتسليح ان تقوم بذلك
هذا يحتاج الى دوله عظمى بحجم الولايات
المتحده لهذا هناك قلق استراتيجي اسرائيلي
في هذا الاطار يخشون بان امريكا والعالم
قد تركوا اسرائيل وحيده ربما بسبب
الانشغال الكبير جدا في الحرب على
اوكرانيا
الملف السابق الذي كنت تناقشه عمليا هذا
الملف قد يكون اخذ الاضواء واسرائيل تخشى
بان العالم عمليا يشيع بنظره عن الموضوع
الايراني النووي وهذا بالنسبه لاسرائيل
تهديد استراتيجي من الدرجه الاولى لهذا
هناك الكثير من القلق وبطبيعه الحال هناك
الكثير من الضجيج دعنا نقول تصريح نتنياهو
الاعلان كل اثنين وخميس عن مناورات مشتركه
تدرب على ضرب المنشات وما الى ذلك هذا
يهدف الى توفير ردع منعا لاستخدام الخيار
العسكري لانه قد يكون الاخير اشكرك جزيل
الشكر من القدس مراسل العربيه زيد حلبي
على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل
دانت وزاره خارجيه النظام السوري زياره
رئيس هيئه الاركان المشتركه الامريكيه
مارك ميلي الى شمال شرق سوريا ووصفت دمشق
الزياره بغير القانونيه معتبره انها
انتهاك صارخ لسياده ووحده البلاد
اظهرت لقطته كاميرات المراقبه والتي نشرت
مؤخرا لحظه هي لمبنى سكني في زلزال قوي في
ملطيه تركيه في السادس من فبراير الماضي
حيث تسببت قوه الزلزال في تفكك المبنى
المكون من سبعه طوابق ما اسفر عن مقتل
تسعه وعشرين شخصا وفقا لمسؤولنا حكوميين
[موسيقى]
اندلعت مواجهات عنيفه بين عناصر من الشرطه
اليونانيه والاف المتظاهرين الغاضبين قرب
مبنى البرلمان وصل عاصمه اثينا واستخدمت
الشرطه الغاز المسيله للدموع لتفريق
المتظاهرين الذين خرجوا فاحتجاجات غاضبه
بعد مقتل العشرات في حادث اصطدام قطاري
مطالبين الحكومه باتخاذ الاجراءات اللازمه
ضد شركه السكك الحديديه بسبب عدم تامين
شروط السلامه المطلوبه لحمايه الركاب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الرابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
في مؤشر المعرفه لعام 2022 السعوديه
الاولى عالميا في مجال التعليم التقني
والتدريب المهني
حياكم الله من جديد تحت شعار نيسر الوصول
للعداله بتقنيات رقميه انطلق اليوم
المؤتمر العدلي الدولي في نسخته الاولى
بالعاصمه السعوديه الرياض بمشاركه 50 دوله
واكثر من 4000 مشارك من مسؤولين وخبراء في
القطاع العدلي يهدف المؤتمر لبحث سبل
تطوير القطاع العدلي وتنميه الخبرات
وتبادل المعرفه لتيسير الوصول الى العداله
اهلا وسهلا وزير العدل السعودي وليد
الصمعاني اول ترخيص لمكاتب محاماه اجنبيه
في السعوديه
الوزير قال خلال كلمته في المؤتمر العدلي
الدولي ان المؤتمر يستهدف بناء الشركات
العدليه ونقل التجارب والخبرات لتطوير
ممكنات العداله حول العالم وشدد وزير
العدل على ضروره مواكبه التغيرات لتحسين
وتطوير ما يتعلق بالتقنيات المعززه
المعززه والتحول الرقمي للضمانات القضائيه
والعدليه
ياتي هذا المؤتمر تاكيدا لرياده المملكه
العربيه السعوديه في مختلف المجالات ومنها
القطاع العدلي الذي يحظى بدعم واهتمام من
لدن خادم الحرمين الشريفين والسمو للعهد
الامير محمد بن سلمان رئيس مجلس الوزراء
وايضا تاكيد للمكانه التي وصلت لها
المملكه على المستوى الدولي كان التفاعل
كبير جدا من العديد من الدول وصل عدد
المشاركين الى اكثر من 50 متحدث ومشارك
وكذلك التفاعل كبير جدا من مختصين
القانونيين لا شك اننا نامل ان يكون بعد
هذا المؤتمر تواصل كبير بين العديد من
وزارات العدل على مستوى العالم في معرفه
اثار التحولات الرقميه والضمانات القضائيه
وترسيخ قواعد العداله من خلال التفاهم
وتبادل الخبرات والاثراء المعرفي بين
مختلف الدول
من المؤتمر العدلي الدولي بالرياضي انضم
الينا مراسل العربيه نواف عزيز نواف مساء
الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض كيف جرت فعاليات اليوم الاول
المؤتمر العدلي الدولي في الرياض
نعم نايف مرحله جديده سيشهدها القطاع
العدلي في السعوديه مع تنظيم النسخه
الاولى من المؤتمر العدلي الدولي
والمشاركه الواسعه من وزراء العدل من دول
عربيه هو اجنبيه وايضا الاعلان اليوم عن
الترخيص لاول ثلاث مكاتب محاماه اجنبيه
للعمل في السعوديه في المشاريع وغيرها
بالتعاون مع مكاتب المحاماه السعوديه
والمحامين السعوديين في هذا اليوم بدا
المؤتمر بافتتاح من وزير العدل الدكتور
وليد الصمعاني وايضا جلسات حواريه شارك
فيها وزير العدل مع وزيره العدل التونسيه
اضافه الى النائب الوكاله الاوروبيه
للتعاون القضائي ناقشوا فيها العديد من
المحاور التي تتعلق بالقضاء والتحول
الرقمي المؤتمر لازال مستمر وسيكون الان
المهندس ياسر السديس وكيل وزاره العدل
للتحول للتطوير والتخطيط اهلا وسهلا مهندس
ياسر في البدايه لماذا هذا المؤتمر ينظم
والى ماذا يهدف حياكم الله وشكرا لكم على
هذه الفرصه مؤتمر العدل الدولي انطلق
بشعار نيسر الوصول للعداله بتقنيات رقميه
وذلك لاستغلال التحول
والتسارع في التحول الرقمي عالميا وفي
يعني توفير العداله للمستفيدين هذا
التسارع واستغلاله يعني فرص كبيره جدا اتى
هذا المؤتمر لبحث هذه الفرص لبحث تحديات
التحول الرقمي في تطبيقه في العداله هل
سيحدث هناك تحديات الاشكالات فلذلك
استقطبنا ولله الحمد خبراء من جميع انحاء
العالم من شرق العالم وغربي شاركوا معنا
من المتخصصين في مواضيع مختلفه كلها تناقش
فرص استغلال التحول الرقمي المتسارع في
تطوير الوصول للعداله للمستفيدين وكذلك
التحديات وكيفيه معالجتها ومناقشتها
الوزاره تهدف من هذا المؤتمر الى كذلك
مشاركه تجربتها في التحول الرقمي والسبق
العالمي لله الحمد الذي حققته في مختلف
المجالات بالتحول الرقمي
والتحديات التي واجهتها في الوصول لهذا
التحول ثم المستقبل الذي تطمح اليه وتطمح
لتحقيقه باستغلال الوسائل الرقميه التي
ستساعد لتحسين تجربه المستفيدين تيسير
الوصول للعداله انجاز الوصول للعداله
باسرع صوره ممكنه باذن الله كيف سيكون شكل
القضاء والمنظومه العدليه في السعوديه بعد
هذا المؤتمر وخلال السنوات القادمه
باذن الله سيحدث هناك تحول كبير استمرارا
للتحول الذي يحصل حاليا من خلال رؤيه
المملكه 2030 ومن خلال برنامج التحول
الوطني
كذلك احد اهداف هذا المؤتمر هو بحث
الفرص التي ممكن ان يتشكل فيها المستقبل
كيف سيكون شكل المستقبل للعداله في ظل
التحول الرقمي المتسارع وخصوصا فيما يتعلق
بالذكاء الاصطناعي لذلك تلاحظ ربما في
برنامج هذا المؤتمر اكثر من جلسه تناقش
الذكاء الاصطناعي واثاره واليات تفعيله
واستغلاله في
تطوير
البرنامج العدلي عموما مهندس ياسر مكاتب
المحاماه التي رخص لها اليوم كيف ستدعم
قطاع المحاماه في السعوديه
ولا الحمد ترخص اليوم لمكتبين بريطانيين
ومكتب امريكي كاول ثلاثه مكاتب محاماه
اجنبيه ورخص لها بالعمل في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
هذه المكاتب حرصنا ان تكون من ذات المكاتب
الادوات الخبره العاليه او العميقه سواء
اعداد العقود او التقاضي فلذلك نتوقع دخول
مثل هذه المكاتب للسوق السعودي سيسهم في
اثراء السوق في اثراء المنافسه في تطوير
السوق السعودي في تدريب المحامي السعودي
في كذلك يعني نقل تجربه
بعض الدول المتقدمه في طريقه تعاملها مع
هذه القضايا المعقده لخصوصا وان المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ولله الحمد تمر بتجربه
تحوليه سيدخل الكثير من الاستثمارات سيكون
هناك موجه كبيره من المستثمرين الاجانب
سيدخلون للسعوديه لذلك هناك حاجه كبيره
جدا لوجود تطور كبير جدا موازي في قطاع
المحاماه الشكر لك مهندس ياسر
العدل حقيقه هي الاجدر بتنظيم المؤتمر
العدلي الدولي والتركيز على التحول الرقمي
نظرا لان وزاره العدل هي الاكثر تقدما في
تحقيق التحول الرقمي ضمن رؤيه 2030 وقد
حققت مؤخرا المركز الاول في مؤشر في قياس
التحول الرقمي الحكومي بنهايه هذا العام
وتعمل على العديد من الخطط والمبادرات ضمن
برنامج التحول الوطني للتحول الرقمي
واستخدام التقنيات في المنظومه العدليه
بالمملكه اشكرك جزيل الشكر من المؤتمر
العدلي الدولي بالرياض الى مراسل العربيه
نواف عزيز
في الكويت وفي اقل من سنه تم تكليف الشيخ
احمد نواف الاحمد الصباح بتولي رئاسه
الوزراء وتشكيل الحكومه للمره الثالثه فقد
اعلنت وكاله الانباء الكويتيه صدور امر
امري بتعيين الشيخ احمد النواف رئيسا
لمجلس الوزراء كما تضمن الامر تكليفه
بترشيح اعضاء الحكومه الجديده
من الكويت ينضم الينا الدكتور سعد بن طفله
وزير الاعلام الاسبق دكتور سعد حياك الله
معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض بدايه كيف
تنظر لاعاده تسميه الشيخ احمد النواف
رئيسا لمجلس الوزراء الكويتي وهل كان
متوقعا
احييكم مشاهديكم وكل عام وانتم بقناه
العربيه بخير
كان يدرك بان سيعيد تكليف سمو الشيخ احمد
النواف رئيس الوزراء وبالتالي فلا مفاجاه
يعني شعاع هناك بان الدكتور محمد صباح
السالم يعني شعبي مواقع التواصل ربما بعض
الصحف يعني بانه هو من سيتولى رئاسه
الوزراء او من سيكلف بتشكيل هذه الحكومه
الجديده
الشاعر لدي مثل ما شاع لديكم يعني بانه
فعلا طلب منه او انه قد كلف ربما برئاسه
الوزراء السابقه ولكن اعتذر وقيل بان
السبب هو اشتراط يعني صلاحيات كامله فيما
يتعلق برئاسه الوزراء هذا ما تم يعني
تداول في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وحينها يعني كانوا الناس يعني يعملون بان
يكون الدكتور محمد صباح السالم خريج هارب
حسين الوزراء ولكن ذلك لم يتم اليوم طبيعه
العلاقه بين المجلس والحكومه دكتور سعيد
اعاده تسميه الشيخ نواف مره اخرى اعاده
تشكيل الحكومه هل تعتقد بان هذه الطبيعه
لهذه العلاقه تعيدنا دائما لنفس المربع
الاول
كم كان بيودي يا صديقي ان اكون متفائلا
على الاقل ككويتي ولكن على الاقل كمراقب
في قناتكم يعني الان من خلال قناتكم لابد
ان اكون موضوعي واقع الحال يقول بان هناك
درجه عاليه جدا من التراجع للاسف الشديد
في حاله التفاؤل التي سادت بالعهد الجديد
بعد خطاب 22 يونيو السنه الماضيه جاءت
الانتخابات بدرجه عاليه من النزاهه ولكن
ايضا هذه الانتخابات ايضا مطعون بعض
نتائجها ومنظور في نتائجها امام المحكمه
الدستوريه لا اريد ان اقول اكثر من ذلك
يعني التزاما بالقانون لا تعليق لا تنتهي
محكمه الدستوريه من النظر في هذه الطعون
ومن ثم نحن امام يعني
الذي لم يستطع التعامل مع البرلمان السابق
هذا البرلمان الان يواجه ربما بعض الطعون
التي قد
تؤدي لا اعرف لا اعرف القراءات المختلفه
ولكن بعض المتابعين يذهبون الى حل
البرلمان واخرين يقولون اعاده الانتخابات
في بعض الدوائر او الغاء نتائجها
الدواليب اريد ان اخلص الليل
للاسم ولا يزال هناك
اكثر قيادي شاغر في الكويت وهذا يدل على
شيء يدل على يعني تراجع الاداري في
الاداره السياسيه من قبل الحكومات السابقه
وبعض هذه المناصب مهمه جدا مثل مدير جامعه
للجامعه الكويت مثل رئيس اركان مثل وزير
دفاع اصلي مثل نائب رئيس اركان وهكذا يعني
الناس الحقيقه تشعر بعدم يعني
بلا تفاؤل خلني ما اقول الكلمه اقوى دكتور
سعد خليني اسالك سؤال يمكن
موجود في دين كل احد يتابعنا الان لماذا
دائما تعود الكويت لذات المربع لماذا
دائما يعني تعود الكويت لحل الحكومه وبعد
ذلك تعيين حكومه تصريف اعمال وتعود
الحكومه وبعد ذلك المواجهه في مجلس الامه
النواب يواجهون الحكومه يتم استجواب
الوزراء استفزاز هذه الحكومه ثم تقديم
الاستقاله بعد ذلك ويعني هذا سيناريو
متكرر للمره الثالثه يعني في اقل من سنه
يعاد تشكيل هذه الحكومه ويعني نحن نتحدث
عن فتره سنه واحده فقط يعني 12 شهرا ثلاث
حكومات
يعني ما هو الخلل يا دكتور او ما هو الحل
لهذا الوضع الموجود اليوم في الكويت
واسع من التعبير عن الراي وربما مليون ونص
الكويتي يمكن تلقى مليار ونصف حل يعني هذه
طبيعه الاشياء يعني الدول التي تتمتع بها
مش يعني واسع من حريه التعبير لكن انا
ممكن اقول لك رايي متواضع يعني
اننا تجربه بنفس الادوات ونت نتائج مختلفه
انا شخصيا اعتقد بانه لا يمكن ان يكون
سواء سمو الشيخ احمد النواف او حتى
الدكتور محمد صباح السالم لو اتى رئيس
الحكومه يمكن ان يكون هناك تعاون بين
السلطتين في ظل اليه اتخاذ القرار الحاليه
التي تشكل يشكل فيها مجلس الامه 50 مجلس
امه خمسين برلمان كل نائب يشك برلمان
بحدده ذاته ويعطي مثل ما تفضلت ربما يعني
صلاحيات واسعه للنواب على حساب مثلا سلطه
كامله ممثله بالسلطه التنفيذيه والعكس
تماما لكن لا نريد ايضا يعني كثير مثلا
المراقبين
الخاصه بهذه التعاون وهذه المسيره في
الوقت الذي ذكرت لك من مثال على سبيل
المثال 500 موقع قيادي شاعر في البلد يعني
ما اعتقد
انه ليش ما تعين وزير الدفاع ولا ما تعين
رئيس اركان ولا مدير الكويت ما راح يوقفه
مجلس الامه صحيح بان هناك من يتمنى وعند
اجندات او عنده تهديده ولكن اذا كانت هناك
عطيه
ان يعوق احيانا يعطل احيانا مثل ما نقول
بالشعب احيانا لكن ليس هو السبب في
المشكله بين السلطتين من السبب يا دكتور
انا مثل ما قلت لكم هذا رايي يعني انا على
الاقل اقول لك رايي متواضع يعني كمراقب
ولكن ايضا كمواطن يعني لاني من 2012 انا
قاطعت الانتخابات ولا ازال واعتقد بان
السير بهذه الطريقه بهذا الشكل سينتج
ويعيدنا الى المربع الاول مره اخرى لاننا
كما ذكرت لك يعني تقصد بان هذه العمليه
السياسيه اليوم يا دكتور في الكويت لم تعد
صالحه
لهذا الوقت لهذا الزمان وهكذا شكل سياسي
يعني حتى غير غير مفيد للكويت نفسها وانا
اللي اقول شذي المؤسسون الذين
وضعوا السنوات ثم
اليه اكثر ديناميكيه نحن لازمنا نراوح على
مدرسه 60 سنه الماضيه بهذا الدستور واعتقد
بانه عامل اواني الى ان يكون في اليه
عصريه وحديثه وعمليه لخلق اجواء واليه
اتخاذ قرار طيب دكتور ايضا هناك سؤال فيما
يخص هذه الحكومه الجديده ماذا لو اعيد
تسميه وزراء كانوا موجودين بالفعل في
الحكومه السابقه او حتى وزراء كانوا من
الوزراء الذين طلب استجوابهم في مجلس
الامه كيف تتوقع حيكون المشهد يعني هذا
جزء من المعضله الحقيقه ان اي لاعب ممكن
يعترض على يعني تعيين وزراء هذا اعتقد
بانه يعني من ضعف الحكومات التي توالت على
السلطه التنفيذي يعني رئيس الوزراء يفترض
ان يكون ممثل للسلطه يعني هي موازيه
السلطه التشريعيه على الاقل دستوريه مع
السلطه القضائيه وراسها سمو الامير لكن
يعني بعض
الحكومه متردده وخائفه وخائفه من البرلمان
ولا اعرف لماذا يعني بس في نفس الوقت اذا
كنت اعتقد بانك ستاتي بنواب سيرضى عنهم كل
الناس فا
[موسيقى]
هو حق دستوري
في نفس الوقت من حق رئيس الوزراء ان يشكل
حكومته كما يرى بالمدينه يعني يترجمون
برنامجك
هل هناك ولم ارى شيئا طيب حتى يعني تشكل
هذه الحكومه ان شاء الله تكون معنا يا
دكتور سعد نناقش ايضا هذه الرؤيه او
البرنامج الحكومي ان تم الاعلان عنا في
قادم الايام من الكويت دكتور سعد بن طفله
وزير الاعلام الاسبق شكرا جزيلا
الرابعه مستمره وفي بعد قليل
السعوديه على ابواب الربيع لكن الشتاء لم
ينتهي بعد فلكيه
الملك سلمان يصدر عده اوامر ملكيه ويعين
سلمان الدوسري وزيرا للاعلام
نقص السلاح يعرقل تصدي القوات الاوكرانيه
للهجمات الروسيه في باقمت والقوات الروسيه
تحاصر المدينه
في المؤتمر العدلي الدولي السعوديه تعزز
انظمه القضاء بالتحول الرقمي وتمنح اول
ترخيص لمكاتب محاماه اجنبيه
في الكويت تكليف احمد النواف الصباح بتولي
رئاسه الوزراء وترشحيح اعضاء الحكومه
الجديده
من المدينه المنوره الى العالم مشروع يسهل
التنقل في الحرم النبوي ويتري تجربه
الزوار في موسم الحج والعمره
حياكم الله من جديد اسهمه المشاريع
الحديثه التي انجزت في المنطقه المركزيه
بالمدينه المنوره في تحسين المشهد الحضري
ورفعي مستوى جوده الحياه المشاريع تركزت
على شبكه الطرق والشوارع المحيطه بالمسجد
النبوي الشريف حيث تم تهيئه ساحه المنطقه
المركزيه للمدينه من خلال توفير الخدمات
والمرافق لخدمه الزوار على مدار الساعه
بالاضافه لاثراء تجربه زوار المدينه في
مواسم الحج والعمره
اعلنا محافظ المؤسسه العامه للتدريب
التقني والمهني في السعوديه احمد الفهد ان
30% من خريجي الثانويات التحقوا بالتدريب
التقني والمهني تصريحات الفيد جاءت بعد
حصول السعوديه على المرتبه الاولى عالميا
في مجال التعليم التقني والتدريب المهني
حسب مؤشر المعرفه لعام 2022 الصادر قبل
نحو اسبوعين
قبل اطلاق الرؤيه كان معدلات من يلتحقون
في التدريب التقني المهني سبعه ونصف
بالمئه من خريج الثانوي بشكل عام طلب ان
نرتفع بهذا النسبه لتواكب على الاقل يعني
طلعات المملكه وان يكون هناك 12.5% من
خريج ثانوي ياتون الى المؤسسه الى مهني في
عام 2020 في ذلك العام حققنا 18%
ثم بعد ذلك ارتفع الطلب على ان يكون ان
شاء الله نحقق يعني معدلات اعلى العام
الماضي مطلوب علينا ان نصل الى 26% حققنا
اكثر من 30% من خريج الثانوي
في السعوديه عدت شركه متخصصه في ابحاث
السوق دراسه حديثه قدرت الزياده السنويه
في الانفاق خلال شهر رمضان هذا العام الى
44% مقارنه بالعام الماضي الدراسه السوقيه
مشاهدينا الحديثه توصلت كذلك الى ان معظم
حجم الانفاق سيسجله قطاع المواد الغذائيه
ثم توصيل الطعام مبرره ذلك بتاثر اكثر من
50% من المستهلكين بالصفقات والعروض
الترويجيه خلال شهر رمضان
اشهد جامعتك غرب السعوديه تدجينا مقر
المركز الاقليمي للتغير المناخي حيث يهدف
المركز الى تعزيز الاداب البيئي في
السعوديه وان يكون مرجعا مهما في الحفاظ
على البيئه واستدامتها كما من المتوقع
ايضا ان يكون مركز الرئيس لتوفير
المعلومات والتحديات من العواصف لمناطق
البلاد ودول الخليج
من جده ينضم الينا البروفيسور ياسر ابو
نجنائب رئيس مركز التغير المناخي بروفيسور
حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
بدايه نريد ان نعرف اكثر عن هذا المركز
ابرز ما يملكه من معلومات
لكي يدعم ايضا المعلومات المناخيه خصوصا
نعم تغيرات المناخيه المتسارعه التي
يشهدها العالم وتشهدها المنطقه تحديدا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين والصلاه والسلام على سيدنا محمد
وعلى اله وصحبه وسلم اجمعين شكرا اخويا
نايف تحت الفرصه هذه الحقيقه اليوم تم
تدشين مركز التغير المناخي في جامعه الملك
عبد الله بحضور معالي وزير البيئه المهندس
عبد الرحمن الفضلي وبحضور الدكتور ايمن
غلام رئيس مركز الارصاد الوطني وهو الداعم
الرئيسي لمركز التغيير المناخي الذي انشئ
في جامعه الملك عبد الله
المركز هذا انشئ بعد ما اعلنوا سمو سيدي
الامير محمد بن سلمان في المبادره الخضراء
بانشاء هذا المركز الذي سوف يخدم المملكه
والدول المجاوره في المستقبل
المركز هو سوف يكون
حجر زاويه اللي داخل المملكه في تقديم
الادوات والمعلومات والتحاليل المناخيه
التي سوف تساعد صناع القرار في المملكه
لاتخاذ القرارات المهمه والاستراتيجيه كما
كما يقوم المركز بوضع الخطط المستقبليه
لعمل استدامه دائمه لحفاظ على
التغيرات اللي بتصير في داخل المملكه
بالنسبه للمناخ هذا بصوره مبسطه اخويا
نايف وش ابرز الخطط والبرامج اللي انتم
حتعملوا عليها يعني سواء على المستوى
الاقليمي على المستوى الدولي تعاونكم ايضا
مع الدول الاخرى هل هو في امداد معلومات
لهذه الدول ام تبادل الخبرات والمعلومات
ايضا حتى كذلك بينهم وبينك وبين هذه الدول
احنا الحقيقه في في المركز الخطط اللي
موضوعه انه احنا فاتحين باب التعاون اول
ما بدانا عملنا ورشات عمل وعملنا مؤتمرات
هنا داخل المملكه مع الدول مع مع
الجهات الحكوميه والخاصه وتعديناهم لتبادل
الخبرات والبيانات معهم كذلك وضعنا تقريبا
قبل شهر مؤتمر مع الدول العربيه وشرحنا
لهم عن المركز واهداف المركز وخططه
المستقبليه
وطلبنا منهم التعاون والتبادل الخبرات
واحنا حنكون في هذا المجال من القاده
الرئيسين في هذا المجال دكتور ايضا نطلب
منك انه احنا نريد رؤيه هذا المركز ونحرك
الكاميرا ايضا نشوف وش موجود في هذا
المركز اذا سمحت تطلب من المصور ايضا
وتشرح لنا بشكل المركز المركز
المركز الحقيقي احنا في جامعه الملك عبد
الله عندنا الحاسوب الخارق شاهين واحنا في
المركز هذا بنستخدم عده نماذج عدديه زي ما
انت شايف امامك هذا اللي هي
النموذج عددي
لحركه التيارات الهوائيه وحركه
التيارات المائيه للبحر الاحمر كما ممكن
اوريك هنا عندنا هنا في الشاشه التي
امامنا امامنا هذا احد النماذج العدديه
الذي يستخدم في الجامعه فاذا احنا اخذنا
مثلا
الرياح نجد استخدام الرياح هنا موجوده في
في
على الشاشه زي ما انت شايفها لو اخذنا
مثلا
لموضوع الامواج في البحر الاحمر او اذا
اخذنا موضوع
زي ما هو واضح امامك كذلك موضوع التيارات
موجوده في في هذه الشاشه وفي هذا المركز
اشكرك جزيل الشكر على هذه الجمله وعلى
وجودك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض جدا
ابو نجا نائب رئيس مركز التغير المناخي
شكرا
اعلن المركز السعودي للارصاد ان المملكه
دخلت فصل الربيع الا انها لا زالت تعيش
اجواء فصل الشيت فصل الشتاء فلكيا واوضح
المركز ايضا ان السعوديه ستشهد موجه بارده
محتمله وسقوط امطار خلال شهر مارس ابجري
كما اشارت التوقعات ايضا بان تبقى درجات
الحراره في معدلاتها
عموما خلال المواسم الانتقاليه التي
نشهدها الان تحصل تقلبات جويه حاده خاصه
في موسم الربيع التفاصيل في التقويم عقد
الزواج
[موسيقى]
مواسم العرب تنقسم الى قسمين مواسم
امتزازيه ومواسم انفصاليه الانفصاليه هي
الفاصله بين الفصول بما يسمى بالربيع
والخريف والامتزاجيه هي التي تعيش داخل
الفصل الواحد يا صيف يشتاء وخلال هذه
الايام نعيش مرحله انتقاليه بين الشتاء
البارد والصيف الحار بما يسمى بالربيع ولا
يغرك دف الربيع ففيه موجه برد قادمه
يسميها العامه برد بياع الخبل عباته الم
ترى ان العقل زين لاهله ولكن تمام العقل
طول
التجارب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وخلال المواسم الانتقاليه تحصل فيه تقلبات
جويه حاده خاصه في موسم الربيع ليش لان
الصيف لا يولد الا بتعسر ويتمثل هذا
التغير بارتفاع وانخفاض في درجات الحراره
وامطار متفرقه بين ان واخر وغبار واتربه
منقوله ومستنكر شيبا قبيل اوانه اقول له
هذا غبار
الوقائعي
[موسيقى]
ختام الرابع بابرز عناوينها
الملك سلمان يصدر عده اوامر ملكيه ويعين
سلمان الدوسري وزيرا للاعلام
نقص السلاح يعرقل تصدي القوات الاوكرانيه
للهجمات الروسيه في باخمت والقوات الروسيه
حاصر المدينه
في المؤتمر العدلي الدولي السعوديه تعزز
انظمه القضاء بالتحول الرقمي وتمنح اول
ترخيص لمكاتب محاماه اجنبيه
في الكويت تكليف احمد نواف الصباح بتولي
رئاسه الوزراء وترشيح اعضاء الحكومه
الجديده
شكرا لكم على كرمه ولطف المتابعه نهايه
الرابعه اعود القاكم غدا في رعايه الله